[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
what's up Prof
hello Walter hi Martin
are you doing well
yes trials when seen as educators will
produce Joy beautiful statement you're
with that that's open with a word of
Prayer
our heavenly father
you promised us trials
and you also said that Jesus went
through all of it so why not we we ask
that you help us through these trials
and that you also blessed this
discussion
and help the viewers to Enlighten their
minds with the holy spirit that all of
us can see the truth in Jesus name amen
amen
so Martin we're going to talk about the
greatest commandment today
and why are we talking about the
greatest commandment
because you remember that we did a
WhatsApp Prof
where we also discussed
the Roe versus Wade issue
and there were some people that
misinterpreted what we have said and
some of them were quite vociferous
to the point of calling us liars and all
kinds of strange things
so it is with that in mind that we
wanted to clarify
why our ministry has a certain angle
and does not necessarily conform to the
angles of other Ministries that's true
because
we have a mission yeah so it is it the
direction that you take
is determined by many many factors
and over the years I've come to the
conclusion that if we concentrate on the
Three Angels messages
then we are addressing the heart of the
matter
and if you really look at it you
encompass
everything
so the greatest commandment we all know
what the greatest commandment is Jesus
defined it for us very well and it's
very often stated in the Old Testament
but let's just first go to that other
discussion
and see what we can learn from it
now it has come to our attention that
there are these thoughts going around
because of the way in which we presented
the issue on abortion that some people
actually believe quite erroneously of
course
that we are pro-abortion or at least I
am
well it's they misinterpreted a lot of
what we've said or a lack of what we say
yes they don't they don't read between
the lines what we are saying so maybe we
must spell some things out so that it
becomes clear this is not in any way an
attack on those that had these ideas
it's let's call it a clarification is it
because it's also been a few people that
misinterpreted
when we were actually discussing
um
offshoots yes they also took it upon
themselves that we were talking about
them so maybe we must just clarify some
of what we mean because
I think we have a a big
viewership that understand what we're
talking about yes but to clarify for the
others yeah and some are new to the
faith so how how is it possible even for
them to you know to grasp all the
nuances of what we are saying so we have
to be we have to be perhaps a little bit
more
careful in how we say things and explain
a little more when we talk about
offshoots we're talking about groups
that call people out of the Fellowship
of The Seventh-Day Adventist Church
we are not talking about people inside
that are upset with issues within the
Seventh-day Adventist Church now are
there issues that we or I personally
would be upset about yes many many
the list is endless and we've had quite
a few discussions on it as well we
mentioned them but we don't go into
details we don't mention names and we
don't go into
assassination principles
but uh we concentrate on the Three
Angels messages and we have to make
quite clear why exactly and why this
impacts how you deal with other issues
it's very important that people
understand that because we always take
you must not get involved in the
politics don't choose a side don't
choose the side don't go left don't go
right be an observer be an observer that
doesn't mean that you don't observe
things on the left or observe things on
the right with which you vehemently
disagree exactly but to start making
those things the issue
you're starting to make it a political
issue and the same or a moral issue a
particular one that's where it comes to
because now when some things are morally
inclined people
choose a side
and then the same happens in the
political sphere yes and you know some
people feel very strongly about some
issues others feel
less strongly about it some field there
are exceptions to a rule some feel there
are no exceptions to a rule
we don't go into those issues at all we
concentrate on the Three Angels messages
and we have to make quite clear why
exactly
so you know I have no beef with people
that find a particular
activity
or some issue highly offensive and will
have a tirade about it and say why they
feel like this but they often feel that
everybody else must climb onto their
soapbox as well and join them
and we have consistently refused to do
that exactly we stay on this Three
Angels messages wall we'll mention these
things exactly that's what I wanted to
just emphasize again these things will
be implemented in on the wall yeah it it
is covered by what the moral message has
to say yes but it's not a sobox message
only correct now if you take the Three
Angels message if you take the first
Angel's message
it starts with worship God
and give fear God and give him the glory
for the hour of his judgment has come
worship Him who may the heavens the
Earth the Sea The Springs of water
that's a very important message so the
first Angel's message starts with God
and that who the true God is and who to
whom the authority belongs correct the
second one and the third one are
addendums
to the first
they are expansions
of uh the acceptance of the authority of
God
now when we look at humanity and we see
how Humanity acts there is no doubt
that God is Not only misrepresented in
the world God is misunderstood in the
world but there is absolute Defiance on
so many levels against the authority of
God
and let's call sin
by its right name sin leads to death
now Martin I can take any particular sin
and to make it my petite yeah
and I can lecture about that sin I can
talk about it and I want everybody in
the world to understand that this sin is
so gross to me that everybody should
join me in my particular
Tech on dealing with this issue is that
right that is exactly what happens
because that's again as we've mentioned
before you choosing a side or you're
getting pulled into the whole thing okay
now there's another person perhaps who
has another son that is petite
and he gets highly upset if you you are
not on his soapbox as well
so how many sub boxes must we climb on
to in order to deal with all the sins of
humanity actually not one
aha actually not one
but I have no beef
if people feel strongly about certain
issues and in actual fact I would
support it because people need to know
what sin is so let's just make that
quite clear but we're going to go to the
greatest commandment but before we do
that let's just look at some of the
comments that have come through as a
result of that last one and see how
people think about it
now before we get there let's just
answer the question why we concentrate
on the Three Angels messages
so this is our backdrop right this is
where our starting point yeah this is
the Crux of the matter yes whenever if
you keep to this
you won't get swallowed in and then
you'll also always see the bigger
picture and that's what we always want
to put the big picture put the puzzle
together
in according to prophecy yes
now everybody knows these quotes but we
today I want to discuss why
these quotes are so important
in a special sense Seventh-Day
Adventists have been set in the world as
Watchmen and light bearers to them has
been entrusted the last warning for a
perishing world
on them shining wonderful light from the
word of God they have been given a work
of the most solemn import the
proclamation of the first second and
third Angels messages there is no other
work of so great importance they are to
allow nothing else to absorb their
attention
now we've had the squad on the screen
numerous times but Martin what does it
mean you are allowed to have nothing
else absorb your attention
don't this must be your focus now you
there are many many roads that lead to
the Three Angels messages and there are
many issues that you can attach to it
but the heart of the issue
should be your focus
is another quote from early writings I
saw a company who stood well guarded and
firm giving no countenance to those who
would unsettle the established faith of
the body
that's quite an interesting statement
when he talks about the body it's
obviously talking about the church
God looked upon them with approbation I
was shown three steps the first second
and third Angel's messages set my
accompanying Angel woe to him who shall
move a block or stir a pin of these
messages
the true understanding of these messages
is of vital importance
I don't think many people realize how
vitally important they are it's a matter
of life and death
the destiny of souls hangs upon the
manner in which they are received I was
again brought down through these
messages and saw how dearly the people
of God had purchased their experience
it had been obtained through much
suffering and severe conflict God had
led them along step by step until he had
placed them upon a solid immovable
platform
Martin that's where I want to be
that is the platform you have to stand
that is the platform I stand upon
that doesn't negate other platforms but
this is the one that we have chosen
so Martin we've we have received some
comments about that last lecture on Roe
versus Wade and all of those things
and let's have a look how some people
interpreted it now
this is not an attack on them this is
how they saw it so obviously we need to
do some clarification and we have to
address it yes
a terrible overreach SDA Pioneers who
are mocked and ignored were as clear
about abortion which they called child
murder as they were about slavery
both were heinous crimes against
humanity and abortion is a very racist
crime
the overturning of Roe versus Wade is
not the joining of church and state what
is he thinking tunnel vision
turning the legality of abortion over to
the States was a common sense move the
first four Commandments are our duty to
God the last six are our duty to man
because of sin the civil government has
had to step in when one of the last six
Commandments are violated the state has
no say in the first four Commandments
and our duty to God that would be a
violation of our Liberty of conscience
it is not a matter of conscience to
decide whether you commit murder or not
that is a crime they do have a say when
murder is committed pay attention folks
no one is infallible
now imagine there are a number of
interesting things regarding this
comment
number one the person feels very
strongly about abortion
that doesn't mean I or you or we don't
feel strongly about it as well right
that's the first issue maybe we must
clarify we will okay we will clarify the
other issue is it is stated here that
abortion is a racist crime
now that is probably because of constant
propaganda by the media that this notion
has gripped through you see so this is
firstly when you get sucked in
politically yes now it might be so that
there might be people who have racist
agendas when it comes to abortion
but whether abortion takes place
in One race or another is irrelevant
abortion is abortion
so there are certain political overtures
here that have been added to the mix
now we never said that that Row versus
Wade was joining of church and state
well if it came across like that that is
not what we meant
now let's just read this point and this
is another comment that that was made I
think the point Walter and Martin have
made is not pro-abortion at all
but in view of that legislation should
not be forged by the church's agenda
regardless of the issue if laws laws are
made in the name of religion the papacy
has an edge and demanding its
absurdities
I think this person grasped more or less
the essence of what we were trying to
exactly we were talking about a bond of
sympathy that is being created
that will eventually lead to swallowing
a hook with the tasty morsels yes right
now there was another one
where the the viewer felt very strongly
that we were totally on the wrong track
and then he went and listened very
carefully again to what we said and he
wrote I have reviewed this video and I
must change what I said originally
now it was obviously on the same
wavelength level more or less as the
previous speaker
firstified mentions and speaks between
44 and 40. what I think is trying to
relay the trend that is happening where
where we are moving along a theme of
agreeing with the papal policies he
isn't saying that agreeing with them on
the point of abortion in itself is
uniting church and state
the dialogue is vague in a certain way I
think and easily misunderstood
at least for a poor slob like me who
isn't very sharp and understanding
things that maybe I should well let me
correct him there he's doing very well
that's what the message that he is
saying that he now understands is
exactly what we were trying to correct
that is what we were trying to say
now Martin we don't have to read at all
I think the point is clear there was
room for misunderstanding
now are there many
different varieties in fact the
smorgasbord of sin available to humanity
Sin is Sin right sin leads to death
uh there are certain sins that are so
heinous
that you cannot even contemplate them
without becoming
terribly Disturbed in in your Psych
so
is this something that we need to go
into great detail or must we rather
address the cause that's it let me make
it quite plain
there are certain issues
where there are no gray areas as far as
I am concerned
and there are other issues where there
might be gray areas
but overall
that doesn't mean that I favor something
because there is a gray area now let me
make it clear I'm not pro-abortion no in
no sense of the fashion but are there
gray areas
yes if the mother's life is in danger
that is a gray area are there other gray
areas where we read about them all the
time and whether you take this view or
that view
it depends on your overall understanding
of the issue now I'm not going to go
into that no they won't climb onto that
sub box no you see that's exactly the
thing we don't go into that detail
that's why the articles that we showed
were showing how ridiculous some of
these things get for instance the
post-natal of seven days or whatever
that you can still have bought after
birth I mean
obviously we are totally ridiculous
that's infanticide as far as I am
concerned and one of the reasons why
people are wanting to do abortions no
we're not going to have a discussion on
abortion it's not our sub box
uh it falls into the broad character
character of rebellion against God God
is the author of Life he's not the
author of death God is not the author of
confusion
Martin let's take another issue
one that is very disturbing to me
and we could make that our sub box if we
wanted to but even there we won't but
let's just use it as an example
namely the issue of
pedophilia
pedophilia where adults
violate small children
to me is one of the vilest crimes that
Humanity can commit and if I had to
choose a sub box to stand on I would
stand on it because in my opinion there
are no gray areas in Peter Philly it is
demonic it is evil in every sense of the
word but Humanity has reached the point
where they are willing to excuse it and
maybe in the future even embrace it
so let's just have a look at this little
video minor attracted persons follow the
Dark Side of Truth
Scholars say pedophilia is now a sexual
orientation that should be accepted by
members of society most of us feel
discomfort when we think about
pedophiles
but just like pedophiles
we are not responsible for our feelings
we do not choose them
but we are responsible for our actions
and we must make a decision
it is in our responsibility to reflect
and to overcome our negative feelings
about pedophiles and to treat them with
the same respect we treat other people
with
we should accept that pedophiles
are people who have not chosen their
sexuality and who unlike most of us will
never be able to live it out freely if
they want to lead an upright life
we should accept that pedophilia is a
sexual preference
now the pope just visited Canada right
and uh very attended a mass
and he also apologized for the sexual
abuses of hundreds
of children
by the church
Now by no means am I saying that this
problem occurs only in the Catholic
Church
it is a problem of humanity
now where do those thoughts and those
ideas come from
the devil they come from Satan yeah
he plants those ideas into humanity and
you can act upon them or you can reject
them decidedly
does that only apply to pedophilia or
does it apply to anything else anything
else
does it apply even to the attraction
between a man and a woman yes
if there's an in appropriate thought in
your mind where does that thought come
from who planted that thought in your
mind yes Satan did Satan did and you
have a choice whether you act upon it or
whether you don't exactly when it comes
to Roman Catholicism
then we note that they more than any
other denomination are plagued with this
particular phenomenon maybe it is
because of their stance on celibacy that
there are more Avenues to the mind that
are created
nowhere in the Bible do we read that
priests were celibate on the contrary if
they weren't married they couldn't be
part of the Sanhedrin
so you know all of these issues play a
role Sin is Sin if an idea of this
nature pops into your mind
then you must deal with it as decidedly
as you would deal with any other disease
that crops up that's inhumanity and
that's true for all sin for all sin
so are there any grades of pedophilia
the fact that you practice it in your
mind but don't practice it on the
outside does that make it right no
because if you put in to context Jesus
telling you that even if you think
something bad against your brother you
commit murder yes and if you look at
another woman it will last after you
have committed adultery so Martin the
issue that we're trying to address here
is sin is a universal problem
now in my opinion pedophilia is
something that would really get me riled
up
but I'm not going to make it the soapbox
because it is just a symptom
it is a symptom of a greater problem yes
and if we don't address the greater
problem then we will constantly sit with
the symptoms that's the cause of the
disease the cause of the disease
so we need to discuss why we concentrate
on the Three Angels messages
and once again just for clarity's sake
that's not meaning that we don't
also strongly feel against all these
other sins absolutely as I said I would
I would happily make one or two of these
issues my soapbox
but I have to war against it
because where is the limit where do you
draw the line
what about uh racial indiscretion I mean
there are parties let's take our country
let's let's have a a little
straightforward chat here
there are parties on both sides of the
color line in this country of ours South
Africa that feel highly offended
about situations
and I can understand why from both sides
are we going to choose sites on the
issue no no because again there are
symptoms of a greater problem and us not
choosing a side does not mean that we
don't see any
um wrongdoing or that there are people
hurting through it
absolutely just not getting into that we
accept that any racial form of racism is
not from God it's not from God by one
blood has he created the whole of
humanity I mean the Bible is very clear
on that issue so let's take an extreme
right-wing position
and look at their list of grievances
many of them are Justified
let's take an extreme left-wing View and
look at their list of grievances many of
them are Justified
are we going to choose a soapbox
no
why are these grievances there and why
are these attitudes there that
eventually lead to hatred and hatred
leads to aggression and aggression leads
to killing your brother that's it you
see if you get pulled in and get a
Showbox to stand on
it's so much harder and we'll get to
that part to do you love your neighbor
part yes
so what is the solution to all of this
you have to transcend the soapbox you
have to
climb above it and if you don't you will
be swallowed in by one ideology or
another how easy is it to sway virtually
an entire nation
into a particular direction
well this is the plan
Been Through the Ages
this is and as it worked yes yes what
what about
the Nazi regime whole nation okay is
Nazism dead no no it's alive and well in
many factions communism
what about communism it's the same thing
they both March exactly the same way to
bring about a uniformitarian mindset
the burial of individualism
okay so we want to address the issue of
why the problem is there in the first
place
now when you go back to the Garden of
Eden
it was a very minor thing
that Eve partook of a fruit
but look at the consequences
that's exactly
all of these issues that we have today
right
why did she partake of the fruit
because she didn't
follow the true Authority
she gave in to want something more than
she thought God gave who planted that
idea in her mind the adversary the
adversary
and what she acted upon
was a distrust and an
unbelief in what God had said that was
the issue
that was the issue so the taking of the
fruit was just a consequence
of a train of thought
that negated what God had said isn't
that right okay
so let's look at the essence of the
Three Angels messages and let's go and
fetch it
right there in the beginning
if we go to the book of Deuteronomy we
read in many many places we've just
taken some of the verses here
Deuteronomy 6 5. and thou shalt love the
Lord thy God with all thine heart and
with all thy soul and with all thy might
chapter 11 verse 1 therefore
Thou shalt love the Lord thy God and
keep his charge and his statutes and his
judgments and his Commandments always
all right it is a commandment you shall
love the Lord your God
you know Martin if I went up to the girl
I fancied and I said to her you shall
love me
that'll work like a child man
you might have a robot loving you
nothing is run into all kinds of
problems now when I was an atheist
this riled me
because after all who was God in my
opinion then in case someone
misunderstands me again
to command love
you can't command love
and why should he command love to such
an extent that it was to be above any
other love yeah some people might say
this is legalism yes all right so God
why would you say you shall
love the Lord your God with all your
heart and with all your soul and with
all your might you shall love him
now firstly we have to understand what
love is that's very important
part of the
the command maybe there's a
misconception about what love is right I
think differently I think so too all
right why is it of Paramount importance
to God
that you should love him
it's a very important question
because it could be because God is a
selfish individual who wants it all for
himself
or there could be a much higher motive
that I in my Fallen State cannot even
comprehend yeah
I've had to make that mind switch in my
life
all right if we go to chapter 11 verse 1
we see something added here therefore
Thou shalt love the Lord thy God and
keep his church and his statutes and his
judgment and his Commandments always
other Commandments and obedience to God
linked to love yes
it's inseparable
you cannot separate them right
all right so
the charge what God has said
the statutes the judgments the
Commandments are linked to love
cannot take them away
so
is God then a control freak because you
have to do these things and you have to
love him no if that's your thought then
modify it that's wrong your
misunderstanding God your
misunderstanding God all right so you
shall love the Lord your God
and you shall keep everything that he
said
let's go a little further
verse 22.
and if you shall diligently keep all
these Commandments which I command you
to do them to love the Lord your God to
walk in all his ways and to cleave unto
him
pretty clear
all right so you must diligently keep
how many of The Commandments all of them
all of them
and then you must love the Lord your God
and you must walk in all of his ways and
you must cleave unto him
it's God being selfish
no and if that's your thought change it
change it you need to understand God you
need to understand love you need to
understand why the Commandments and the
judgments and the statutes and the
charge are linked
inseparably
from the love of God
you need to understand that if you don't
you're going to have to get a sub box
that's the problem yeah and you could
have a soapbox where God is your pair
tight exactly I had that sub box
I hated god with a passion
he was the one don't do what I say and I
throw you in hell for all eternity huh
that was the god that I looked upon in
the past
and my soapbox disintegrated it melted
it's gone I don't have one to stand on
anymore I was 100 wrong in my estimation
let's go to chapter 30 verse 6 and the
Lord thy God will circumcise thine heart
and the Heart of thy seed to love the
Lord thy God with all thine heart and
with all thy soul that thou mayest live
that's a powerful one
all right now let's see what's attached
to love the Lord your God
will change your heart
can you see why this is the essence
it's not the issues
that we are talking about
it's the lack of something it's the lack
of relationship with God that brings
about the possibility for all of these
issues no matter how vile or
insignificant they might be absolutely I
was listening to a sermon by one of our
pastors
and he was saying that the Ten
Commandments is part of the Covenant
that's why it's in the Ark of the
Covenant if you take the Ten
Commandments the tablets
out of the Ark of the Covenant then
you've only got the Commandments but you
don't have a relationship then it's
legalism that's when you start climbing
onto show boxes all right now if you
take the Commandments out modern
do they still then have a mercy seat
covering them no so if you've taken them
out of the Ark
then they can actually lead to death
exactly huh because you're not being
covered by The Mercy Seat and everything
is just jointed then
could you perhaps modify those Ten
Commandments to Suit Yourself are there
churches that have done that that's it
both Catholic originally and Protestant
subsequently
okay all right so let's just unpack this
a little bit more God will change your
heart that's what it promises here
he'll change your heart to love the Lord
your God
and why is that essential
so that you may live yeah if you don't
have this combination you're going to
what
don't die you're going to die
someone is it essential that we get this
right yes it's a relationship okay can I
force love
okay no can you can I force obedience to
the Commandments
you can force it
but it will disjoin the relationship yes
so it will not work no therefore can I
legislate Commandments
now the one comment was yes I can the
state has the duty to legislate
Commandments like do not murder for
example
uh can the state legislate the mind no
so if I had my brother I've already
committed murder so the state has a very
limited scope in which it can legislate
exactly and there are certain other
issues that it cannot legislate at all
that doesn't mean that it shouldn't
legislate and if they legislate say
something like Roe versus Wade Etc
then that doesn't mean that I'm anti the
legislation I'm anti the sin that's it
okay it's leading to to a fulfillment of
Prophecy yes all right we have to unpack
this so we have to know what it means
when it says love the Lord your God
love is a a very complicated word and we
will have to talk about that and you
have to do it with all your heart
and if you don't you won't live
now Psalms 97 verse 10. ye that love the
Lord
hate evil
so something happens in the mind
that when you love God
then automatically you start hating evil
all evil all evil no matter
what kind of evil even a look can be
evil yeah
and before you might not have recognized
it but the demeanor of a person the look
in the eyes will tell you is that is
that the look of someone who has
recognized the righteousness of Christ
or is that a look that has a dark shadow
okay
he preserveth The Souls of his Saints he
delivereth them out of the hand of the
wicked
that's a beautiful promise
so if you love the Lord then you will
hate evil
but if you at any level
go against evil
you will have peer pressure applied to
you to commit evil you know
school children are they constantly
constantly bombarded with peer pressure
if they're taking drugs don't they want
everybody to take drugs nobody wants to
sin alone
that's so true yeah
when it comes to perversions
attached to everybody they have to have
a body they have competitions to see how
perverse they can become
but if you love God then you will hate
evil
and he will preserve your soul
and he will deliver you out of the hand
of the wicked he'll give you a way of
Escape
doesn't mean you won't be bombarded
Proverbs 8 verse 13 the fear of the Lord
is to hate evil ah
is this perhaps a synonym
the fear of the Lord leads you to hate
evil the love of the Lord leads you to
hate evil that's it now what does it
mean the fear of the Lord
the respect respect
respect God for what he is so when you
respect God
you will hate evil
you will hate Pride
you will hate arrogacy you will hate
every evil way you will hate every
frowed mouth
because God hates it yeah
it becomes
it becomes abhorrent to you
right all of it all these evil okay now
some people believe that if you're
living in an evil age you have to
isolate yourself from this evil Enoch
walked amidst the evil
and yet he wasn't contaminated by the
evil because evil had become abhorrent
to him that's the point we have to
arrive at
now again we're not going to identify
every form of evil we're not going to
make it the soapbox because this is the
essence of the matter this is why it
even has a foothold
because the first commandment to love
God
has been neglected
so let's go to what Jesus said
Matthew 22 verse 37 Jesus said unto him
Thou shalt love the Lord thy God with
all thy heart and with all thy soul and
with all thy mind is quoting Deuteronomy
right that's it
this is the first and great commandment
and the second is like unto it
does not love thy neighbor as thyself on
these two Commandments hang all the law
and the prophets
so love God love your neighbor
summarizes the law of God that's it
that's what it says right
but he says the first one
and the great commandment is to love God
but then he says the second one is like
it
but it's still the second one the second
one because you cannot do the second one
if you do not have a first one exactly
it's not a true the definition of Love
gets lost if you don't do the first one
you have to have the first one because
God is the one who enables you
to have the second one
all right so there were two tables of
stone
and love for God is summarized on the
first one
is that under attack in the world
definitely all right we've had lecture
and lecture and lecture upon it so the
authority of God isn't set aside in the
world
and this is a great evil because once
you set the side the authority of God
you're listening to the serpent
yeah the serpent said did God really say
the serpent said it'll surely not be
like that it'll be the other way
so believing the serpent
led to the misery that we have
did it lead to
promiscuity yes
did promiscuity lead to abortion
exactly right so you can trace all sin
all sin come from this base
please don't misunderstand us again but
this is the issue why we concentrate on
the Three Angels message we have to say
why you know we talk a lot about the
Sabbath yeah now some people will say
now how can you possibly say
that whether you go to church on a
Sunday or a Saturday is even remotely
comparable to the issue of abortion or
pedophile
well we will see why exactly I won't
jump the gun let's not jump the gun
all right so on these two hang the law
and the prophets
Jesus qualifies it goes even further
Matthew 10 verse 37 he says he that
loves father or mother more than me is
not worthy of me and he that loves son
or daughter more than me is not worthy
of me
my goodness I would say that is the most
selfish statement that you could
possibly read from any individual
if you don't love me more
then you love your own wife or your own
child
you're damned hmm
but what if we turn it around yeah just
to turn it around let's just turn it
around if you don't love me more
then your father and your mother
eventually you're going to go down the
slippery slope of sin now if you turn it
around you say if you love me you will
love your mother and your father and
your brother and you will be able to
love them no matter what they whisper in
your ear
right that's it but you will be able to
discern what is right and what is wrong
because God will give you the capacity
it is Paramount
that you put God first
so that you can love your father
so that you can love your mother so that
you can love your son so that you can
love your daughter even if they go
astray that's it the true meaning of
love will come through if you do the
first part in loving God you can
interpret any one of these by coming to
the conclusion that God is the most
selfish being in the universe
or you if you study it through might
come to the conclusion or hopefully will
come to the conclusion
that if you don't put God first
then you are going to be doomed
to sit with the consequences of sin
so John 14 15 says if you love me
then you will keep my Commandments
and if you say that you know him and you
keep not his Commandments then you are a
liar and the truth is not in you we've
used these verses many times but this is
how deceiving sin is
if you don't love God
you cannot keep the Commandments
you might have rules
that you enforce but you cannot keep
them because
if you love God even your mind you will
be guarded exactly because like you've
mentioned before you can have rules that
say don't murder but your mind can still
do it yes now we're not going to go into
gray areas because we don't choose soap
boxes
but take any
any activity that deviates from God's
original plan any activity that deviates
from God's original plan
and try to excuse it by saying I Was
Born This Way
or I cannot help the way I think
is highly problematic if you make God
first
then all things can come back into
harmonics with his principles that's a
very important statement when you do it
it will come back in harmony okay now
let's go back even further
why has God got the right
to tell us these things
let's see
so I've titled it here the Lord's claim
Isaiah 45 Verse 18 and thus says the
Lord that created the heavens
God himself that formed the Earth and
made it
by the way is that part of the first
Angel's message yes
very much so right worship Him who made
he has established it
he created it not in vain
he formed it to be inhabited I am the
lord and there is none else
this is a very powerful statement it is
and you asked the question earlier
why would the Sabbath be more important
than abortion hmm
let's let's just go into it don't jump
the gun Martin sorry you're an impatient
fellow here today
I'm gonna rain myself in the rain let's
rain ourselves in all right what's very
important in here is he's the Creator
God he's your creator
imagine when I when I see this creation
thing
vulnerati comes to mind the advisor to
Klaus Schwab who says that we're even
greater than God because we can now
create life and not only organic life
but we can create electronic life you
know artificial intelligence we're even
greater than God I I I shudder when I
think of the patheticness of it
organic life is so complex that only God
himself
could put that together
and then when we talk about Ai and all
of these things what are they using
they're using what's already there the
forces of nature who put those forces
into nature God is laughing at their
ridiculous statements but let me not go
there because also I'll climb on a
soapbox and get all angry and Twitter
and busted you see I'm glad you're not
on a soapbox because you wouldn't have
ever gotten off your creation anymore
yeah it's not it's a worthy soap box it
is I'm not arguing against the
worthiness but it's encompassing it's
the whole truth and it's not as if
people didn't try to keep you on that
box as well yes there were many attempts
to keep me on one box don't go into this
Three Angels message business but if we
don't we miss the point all right so why
did he created it it didn't create it in
vain he formed it to be inhabited
I am the lord and there is none else
I'm your Creator God I created this
world I created it not for nothing
to be inhabited by whom by you and me
so what does he want
he wants a relationship that's it he
wants a relationship on Whose terms
Easter Easter yeah why has he got the
right to say that he's got the right and
he knows best all right so he obviously
thought this thing through right
now if you look at nature and you see
the beauty of Nature and you see the
interplay that we have in nature and you
know the codependence that we have in
nature and just the
finesse and the beauty and the
magnificence of it what does that tell
you about God
he knows best he knows best all right so
he created it to be inhabited and he
laid the groundwork and set the rules as
to how it shall be
you don't like it you don't want it
you're free to opt out
and you're gone and then you have to
live with the consequences which is
oblivion is it okay Jeremiah 31 verse 3
the Lord has appeared of old unto me
saying yea I have loved thee with an
Everlasting Love Therefore with loving
kindness have I drawn thee
all right God doesn't only command that
we love him
he tells us that he loves us yeah and
that he will establish that you can love
him
so it's a very reciprocal relationship
so he created us for a reason he wanted
the Earth to be inhabited not as a
PlayStation
but as a relationship
and this relationship
is love
okay we have to Define that
now
eternal life therefore is conditional
Deuteronomy 30 verse 19 I call Heaven
and Earth to record this day against you
that I have set before you life and
death blessing and cursing therefore
choose life that both thou and thy seed
may live
bottom line the Lord's claim
I created the earth I created all things
I created you I wanted to I want to have
a relationship with you I love you but
there are certain things that you have
to do in order to qualify
for eternal life within this realm to
make this relationship work okay and if
you don't like it then you can go back
to where you were Oblivion
that's the Lord's claim yeah take it or
leave it now God could be a monster
and you might want to leave it
but God could actually be the most
magnificent the most wonderful the most
loving the most
compassionate being in the entire
universe and your joy is just
unspeakable if you embrace it why would
you want to give it up then
that you wouldn't only if you listen to
a false
adversary all right now how do you
acknowledge the Lord's claim
so the Lord makes a claim
and he says this is this is the status
quo
I have created you I've given you a
beautiful home
I want a relationship with you that
relationship has to be built on trust
respect and love
and here are the rules
okay
let's go acknowledging the Lord's claim
Isaiah 56 6 also the sons of The
Strangers
he's talking to the Jewish Nation
that joined themselves to the Lord to
serve him and to love the name of the
Lord
to be his servants everyone that keepeth
the Sabbath from polluting it and taketh
hold of my Covenant
this is fascinating so all people must
get to know this God
and they must join themselves to God and
when they do that they must love the
name of the Lord
now previously it says You must love God
now it says You must love the name of
the Lord
as his character
so you must make a study of the
character of God and then you must
decide I want this
you must love the character of God
and then you want to be his servant and
Jesus said I no longer call you servants
I call you brothers and sisters
isn't that amazing amazing okay everyone
what's this here Martin why does it drop
the Sabbath into it
because that's these relationship Mark
all right everyone that keeps the
Sabbath from polluting it and takes hold
of my Covenant
now the Covenant is a legal document
yeah it's a a document where two parties
decide to keep to a particular regime
right and God has made it quite plain
I'm your creator here are the rules this
is where you're going to live we're
going to have a relationship and if you
don't like it you can opt out yeah you
can choose here are the conditions for
staying within the Covenant here are the
conditions for excluding yourself from
the Covenant you may choose is that
unfair as the Creator no no
no it is right this is right he he
established it and he wants
that and the whole time
he initiates this okay now why does he
linking to the Sabbath what has the
Sabbath but got to do with your decision
to come into a covenant relationship and
a love relationship with God can I
answer it you're supposed to
acknowledgment that he is the one that
you want to be in a relationship with
aha so he's made the Sabbath a sign
Ezekiel
that I am the Lord that sanctifies you
in other words I am the Lord
that helps you in your mind to hate evil
that's it
and by keeping the Sabbath I will
establish that
and the Sabbath is the sign that you
have accepted the authority of God
because
we just read that he created the heavens
the Earth to see the Springs of water
was that in the first Angel's message
yes is it in the Sabbath Commandments
yes ah it's the same so can you separate
the Sabbath commandment from the first
Angel's message
no you know what you cannot not keep the
Sabbath if you love God all right if
you're keeping the Sabbath now
is it now an issue of
you should do Wednesday or Thursday or
Sunday or a Monday or a Saturday
no
but God said the seventh day
is the Sabbath
if you say yes to that
you are saying
your Authority is Paramount to me I will
accept it the serpent climbs into the
tree and says I've changed it to Sunday
come and keep mine and I will sanctify
you I will give you ceremonies I will
give you sacraments and I will ensure
that you get eternal life then what must
I say no thank you no thank you because
your command is contrary to God's mind
you come on you're telling me I must
follow your Authority and acknowledge it
by keeping the first day of the week
when God said I must follow his
authority and acknowledge it by keeping
the seventh day of the week so I am
accepting God's Authority when I keep
the Sabbath
it's not rocket science and he says I'm
the Lord that sanctifies you
then he tells me you know if you if you
have accepted this if you've joined
yourself to the Lord to love my
character
and you're keeping the Sabbath as an
external sign that you have actually
done this
then I will teach you to hate sin
so if you're keeping the Sabbath in
order to be saved
you've missed the point maybe I must
then clarify just for in case somebody
misunderstood me earlier when I said
it's impossible to love God without
keeping the Sabbath
it must be the right sequence
if you want to keep the Sabbath to be
saved
that won't work won't work the
relationship comes first and what about
people that don't know this
we've spoken about that numerous time of
ignorance God Winks that let's not go
there but this is the issue you cannot
divorce the Sabbath because it is the
sign of his authority
it is a sign between me and the children
of Israel forever for the stranger that
joins themselves to this faith
Isaiah 56 7 even them
in other words these strangers that's
you and me Martin
will I bring to my Holy Mountain and
make them joyful In My House of Prayer
their burnt offerings and their
sacrifices will shall be accepted upon
mine Altar for mine house shall be
called a house of prayer for all people
the Lord God which gathers the outcasts
of Israel said yet will I gather others
to him besides those that are gathered
unto him it is universally it applies to
the whole of humanity
irrespective where you come from the
Sabbath is the issue of authority
now Martin we also need to clarify what
is love
doesn't people don't have a concept of
what is like I thought Hollywood did a
good job yes they're doing a good job at
giving the other side of what love is
leading you into sin
in fact
the best thing that could happen to that
box is for a millstone to be tied to its
neck and thrown into the sea
and uh sin should become exceedingly
sinful
now what is love you know Peter had to
learn what love is
do you love me
more than these
after he had denied him three times
not I Lord I will go through the ends of
the Earth I will never leave you
and then Jesus came to him and he said
do you love me agape
and Peter answered you know that I file
you
Peter do you Agape
more than these
you know Lord that I file you
and the third time
Peter do you file me
and then he was exceedingly sad the Lord
took a step down
because Peter had demonstrated that he
wasn't capable of
unselfish love
now the Greeks didn't regard Agape as
the highest form of love Eros
was the highest form of love it's not
mentioned in the bible once
it doesn't belong there
it's that passionate yeah love between a
man
and a woman these days you would
rephrase that but I'm not going to go to
that soapbox
so the bottom line is Peter realized
that he didn't have this love
he'd never knew what it was
until it failed him the love that he had
it failed him because he didn't have
that love
but he had to get to that love yes
that's why later on when you read about
Peter's experiences and how he deals
with it he mentions his ladder the
ladder that you climb you have to add to
your faith virtue and then he gives this
long list any ends
with agape
so in other words he knows where we have
to go to now that's something that is So
Divine
that we cannot attain it only God can
give it to you like he mentioned in the
verses before he
does that work inside correct so what is
love Martin
let's read a few things in
the statements of the spirit of Prophecy
the love of Christ is not a fitful
Feeling
but a living principle which is to be
made manifest as an abiding power in the
heart
if the character and deportment of the
shepherd is an exemplification of the
truth The Advocates the Lord will set
the Seal of his approval to the work the
shepherd and the flock will become one
United by their common hope in Christ
so modern love is not a feeling it is a
principle
and once this principle is enacted there
can be Unity do we have Unity at the
moment no
you're so adamant what's wrong with you
if they don't have Unity no because if
there was Unity the job would get done
the job would get done we would stop
shouting at each other running each
other down we would be on the wall with
the sword in the one hand and the trowel
in the other hand and we would be
building the wall there's a bridge in
the wall exactly get off the soapbox get
on the ladder up to the wall get onto
the wall there is a bigger principle
that is at stake here
Supreme love for God and unselfish love
for one another this is the best gift
that our heavenly father can bestow
this love is not an impulse
but a Divine principle a permanent power
the unconsecrated heart cannot originate
or produce it
only in the heart where Jesus Reigns is
it found we love him because he first
loved us
in the heart renewed by divine grace
love is the ruling principle of action
it modifies the character governs the
impulses controls the passions
ennobles the affections this love
cherished in the soul sweetens the life
and sheds a refining influence on all
around
Martin Is This Love abounding in our
church
not yet not yet right
let's go on
true love is a high and holy principle
all together different in character from
that love which is awakened by impulse
and which suddenly dies when severely
tested
love is a plant of heavenly growth it
must be fostered and nourished
affectionate Hearts truthful loving
words will make happy families and
exerting elevating influence upon all
who cometh in the sphere of their
influence Martin if we were to
concentrate on this
there would be such a change I love that
word elevating influence it will get you
out of this nonsense
and a little bit higher if we swim in
the Cesspool lamenting the cesspool
how can we get to this level
you cannot you cannot so the
relationship and the trust that you have
in God
the respect that you have for God the
respect for his
Divinity the respect for his capacity
has created God the respect for his
rules of Life which are so absolutely
logical
that is the issue at stake
so the first Angel's message says
worship God and give glory to him
because there is a judgment coming
it's already
ongoing it's already ongoing and the
second Angel's message says
Babylon has fallen yeah why because
they've made their own rules because
they didn't do they didn't do as God
said they took those Commandments out of
the Ark they're not covered by a multi
seed some of them through the
Commandments in the waste paper basket
and don't even have commandments so what
do they need a mercy seat for
this is so ridiculous if you set God
aside you have the terrible situation in
the world which we all lament at every
single level whether it is the issue of
abortion whether it is the issue of
pedophile whether it is the issue of
racial divide whether it is the issue of
gender whether it is bashing of other
genders either man bashing a woman or a
woman bashing a man or disrespect for
the human body all of these issues even
if it's the issue of showing out the
people in
leadership
yes now does this mean Martin that you
may never address sins no of course you
must address them
but if you neglect the cause
you're always going to sit with the
issue
so true love versus passion
we might as well rephrase this true love
versus Hollywood that's it well put
love is not unreasonable
it is not blind
it is pure and holy you know I can add
something there
that is highly biblical
it covers a multitude of sins
if I were to concentrate
on the transgressions of everybody
around me
I would be the most domineering
high-minded pharisaical individual on
the planet
if I have
God's love
then I will have compassion for the
weakness not excusing it no no
because remember when when God said to
Moses I will let my glory pass by you
and he said the Lord gracious and all of
those wonderful adjectives
by no means excusing the guilty we
cannot separate Justice and mercy
but I would have compassion
and sometimes the Lord aloud in our
lives situations
so that we cannot say we are better than
others because we probably even did
worse than they did
so you know I always use the example
somebody walks into the church
there are more nose rings and lip rings
and who knows what rings in that person
tattoos from the top to the bottom
and you say what is that individual
doing in my church
that person is coming into the church
because there's a cry for help
right
somebody once came up to me and said
so you're going to condemn me because my
whole body is covered with tattoos
and I said to him you know some people
carry their scars on the inside and some
people carry them on the outside but we
all have scars
so how do we treat
people how do we interact with one
another
do we go on a bandwagon and start
calling people Liars because they don't
see something exactly like we see it or
they don't voice their opinion as
forcefully as you yes
so let's say Martin
I had to deal with someone who has
committed an abortion
and what will be my attitude towards
that individual how do I deal with that
individual I have to ask myself the
question before I do it
how would God do it exactly because if
you put yourself in this scenario that
person walks into the church and you are
standing on your soapbox screaming the
whole time of our how wrong it is how
can you are you going to help this
person yes I know someone in our family
that totally withdrew from society
for her entire life
because when she was young
and it was many years ago so the issue
was you know still far more stringent
than it is today
uh had an abortion
because she was so afraid of what her
parents would say or a father would say
if
it was found out that she had a
relationship before she was married
and uh
when the abortion was done it was twins
she never forgave herself never ever
forgive herself
and went to the Grave that way
now
if we had the love of God
we could we could work through that
and if that person could then look at
God and accept
the love of God and the Forgiveness of
God
then one might be able to deal with some
of these issues you know some people
carry their sins with them even if they
confess them
it's like digging up the dog that's been
buried over and over again lamenting the
fact that the dog has been buried
once you have confessed your sins
and forsaken your sins don't dwell on
them no don't take it back from God
don't take it back he's forgiven it as
far as the East is from the west and
don't give Satan the pleasure
of distrusting God in terms of his
forgiveness
but let's not go there we could have a
long discussion
so love is not unreasonable it's not
blind it is pure and holy but the
passion of the natural heart is another
thing altogether
while pure love will take God into all
its plans and will be in perfect harmony
with the spirit of God
passion will be headstrong rash
unreasonable defiant of all restraint
and will make the object of its Choice
an idol
in all the deportment of one who
possesses true love the grace of God
will be shown modesty Simplicity
sincerity morality and religion will be
characterized every step towards an
alliance in marriage
those who are thus controlled will not
be absorbed in each other's Society at a
loss of interest in the prayer meeting
and the religious service
they're further for the truth will not
die on account of the neglect of the
opportunities and privileges that God
has graciously given to them Martin if
you have true love for God you must have
true love for your brethren
with their mistakes does God love you
even though you have mistakes you've
become faultless now I know right
you're not faultless
oh yes you have someone to remind you of
them
I think God graciously gave us those who
remind us of our works
so it's so easy to start focusing on
other people's quirks yeah that you
don't see your own so if occasionally
you have to be forcefully reminded of
your Quirk so that you can learn
compassion for other people's works and
you know you might have overcome one
thing
but are battling with another and the
other person might have the reverse
and you will condemn that person
no we must not constantly be
compassionate
that love which has no better Foundation
than mere sensual gratification will be
headstrong blind and uncontrollable is
that what we see in the world yep
why because they've neglected the love
of God yeah the First Command that
Essence honor truth and every noble
elevated power of the Mind are brought
under the slavery of passion
the man who is bound in the chains of
this infatuation is too often deaf to
the voice of reason and conscience
neither argument nor entreaty can then
lead him to see the Folly of his cause
is society making excuses for sin yeah
once it has made excuses for sin will it
go so far as to legislate it yes
yes Martin where are we going
Three Angels messages
worship God fear God respected
because he's the Creator there's a
judgment coming
don't go the way of Babylon don't go the
way of Babylon because Babylon is going
to compromise with sin it's going to
redefine sin
it's going to tell you sin is separation
from God now sin caused separation from
God
don't come along Babylon has fallen has
fallen and she's pouring out wine false
Doctrine
and don't accept the mark of the beast
the mark of the beast
is the opposite of the mark of God the
Seal of God
and that's found in the first Angel
already that's found in the first Angel
and it's in the Sabbath command that is
the seal I am the Lord your God
therefore I commanded you to keep holy
the Sabbath day it is the Seal of God
and the mark of the beast is the
contrary thereof it is Sunday keeping
because it says that follow God don't
trust him to bring you salvation I will
give it to you my way and that's the
choice
and if you don't make the right choice
there all the rest
with nothing nothing with nothing yeah
so true love is not a strong fiery
impetuous passion on the contrary it is
calm and deep in its nature it looks
beyond me externals and is attracted by
qualities alone it is wise and
discriminating in its devotion is real
and Abiding Love Lifted out of the realm
of passion and impulse becomes
spiritualized and is revealed in words
and acts
a Christian must have a Sanctified
tenderness and love in which there is no
impatience or fretfulness the rude harsh
manners must be softened by the grace of
Christ
Have you listened to some political
debates lately
Martin are they rude harsh mannered
fretful impatient I think the majority
of humanity has become so where's the
essence of the problem the love for God
love for God
sentimentalism is to be shunned as
leprosy imagination
lovesick sentimentalism should be
guarded against as would be the leprosy
there goes all Hollywood Productions
very many of the young men and women in
this age of the world are lacking in
virtue therefore great caution is needed
those who have preserved a virtuous
character although they may lack in
other desirable qualities may be of real
moral worth
and you cannot have it if you do not
make God first it's the first and
greatest commandment and it is the
essence of the Three Angels messages and
that is also why when you preach
the Commandments and you cannot we've
seen you cannot separate it from the
love of God because it is character
that's why when you understand that how
can people tell you you must preach the
love of Christ but not this legalism
it's it's totally distorted let's just
go to the second tablet because it's
like unto the first right
so the claims of the Second Great
commandment
Leviticus 1917 says Thou shalt not hate
thy brother in thine heart
Thou shalt in any wise rebuke thy
neighbor and not suffer sin upon him
this almost looks contradictory
so you may not hate your brother but you
may tell him what is right and what is
wrong when he's doing something
specifically wrong but you may not hate
him
1 John 3 14 we know that we have passed
from Death unto life because we love the
brethren he that loveth not his brother
abide Us in death how can how can God
say that
because you've neglected the first
commandment you're incapable of this one
yeah and neglecting the first
leads to death leads to death
and the only one who can change this
mind of yours is God and give you this
compassion is God himself
1 John 4 20 if a man say I love God
and he hates his brother he's a liar
for he that loveth not his brother whom
he has seen how can he love God whom he
has not seen
none is it possible
to love your brother and not like him
yes
yes it is quite possible
to not like someone now one why is it
that there are certain people that you
don't like
what is it that makes you not like them
they're mannerism yeah whatever they do
now that which they do
comes from what
what they believe all right so if you
find someone that is not likable
that should spurn you to Greater Love
Now Greater Love had no one than he who
laid down his life while you were yet a
sinner
so the fact that you don't like him
you should
instill in you feelings of love
now God has given us families it's given
us children
it's very easy not to like what some of
your children are doing
and then if they are
very stubborn in this it is maybe
possible to not even like them anymore
but can that negate love no no it cannot
right it cannot
1 John 4 21 and this commandment have we
from him that he who loveth God
love his brother also
it's it's a given the example of this I
just think again of Jesus
hanging on the cross
saying father forgive them for they know
not what they do all right now that
we've had all of these verses as you
have said they know not what they do
it's jump to the first one again
Thou shalt not hate thy brother
in thine heart Thou shalt in any wise
rebuke thy neighbor and not suffer sin
upon him
you may say what is wrong what they are
doing wrong
but you may not condemn your brother you
must love him okay
so how do we address the brethren in the
church mutton it has become a habit
to bash
people within the church
and uh it's something that sometimes one
feels inclined to do
but you have to fight the impulse
right yes so here is a statement from
the spirit of Prophecy that hopefully
will wrap this thing up
shall we go for it let's go for it let's
go for it
you will have many perplexities to meet
in your Christian Life in connection
with the church
you know Paul had a long list of things
that happened to him he was stunned he
was you know the list is England he was
in the Deep he was washed away from this
sore he was Shipwrecked he was beaten up
you know he had a long list and he ends
up with the Brethren he had a cherry on
top
now in my life I've had a long list with
the Brethren and there were occasions
when my feelings were
unkind to say the least
or my thoughts
and it took some serious introspection
and some serious prayer sometimes to get
them sorted out again I'm not saying
it's perfect but I'm working at it it's
a work in progress
all right so especially perplexities
that we will meet in the church and then
this statement but do not try too hard
to mold your brethren
if you see that they do not meet the
requirements of God's word do not
condemn if they provoke do not retaliate
when things are said that would
exacerbate quietly keep your soul from
fretting
you must labor for the earring with the
heart subdued softened by the spirit of
God
and let the Lord work through you the
agent
roll your burden on Jesus you feel that
the Lord must take up the case where
Satan is striving for the Mastery over
some soul
but you are to do what you can in
humility and meekness and put the
Tangled work that complicated matters
into the hands of God
follow the direction in his word
and leave the outcome of the matter to
his wisdom having done all you can to
save your brother cease worrying
and go calmly about your other pressing
duties it is no longer your matter but
God's
let's make it quite plain we've made a
decision to be on the wall to bring the
Three Angels messages because if you get
that right the rest will come right by
itself because God will take care of it
yes I can address sin
but I may not be asked to my brother
do not through impatience cut the knot
of difficulty making matters hopeless
let God untangle the snarled up threads
for you he is wise enough to manage the
complications of Our Lives he has skill
intact we cannot always see his plans we
must wait patiently they're unfolding
and not Mar and Destroy them
he will reveal them to us in his own
good time
seek for Unity cultivate love and
Conformity to Christ in all things he is
the source of unity and strength if you
do as God would have you his Blessing
will come into the church
may I appeal to all the Brethren out
there
we are all fighting a war against evil
but the ultimate answer
is to make God first
that's what the Three Angels messages
are all about
give God the glory he is the creator he
has given you a sign do not follow
Babylon and do not follow a false seal
of approval
stick to what God has said and he will
join you to him as you want to be joined
to him
and he will change your mind
so with that in mind let us wrap up this
subject and leave it to God
and pray
Heavenly Father
sin
is Raging like a fire out of control
and the only solution
is for Humanity to turn to God
with every fiber of their being
to trust the Lord their God to believe
in the Lord their God
and to implement his will and join with
him in a solemn Covenant
help us to achieve this through the
messages of the Three Angels is my
prayer in Jesus name amen amen
[Music]
thank you